good afternoon everyone thank you for
being here with me today
i want to come before you today to talk
about nevada's residential eviction
moratorium as many of you know we
originally implemented an evictions
moratorium
early on in the covit 19 pandemic in an
effort to help everyone be able to stay
home from nevada
and slow the spread of covet 19.
throughout the pandemic this moratorium
has been extended
as the situation with covet 19 evolved
and over the last year the state has
partnered with counties to set up rental
assistance programs
and work with the judiciary and the
legislature to create a rental mediation
program
much progress has been made but there is
still more work to be done
our state is currently going through a
large scale transition period
as we continue to navigate the
ever-evolving pandemic
and subsequent crises kids are back in
school
we we're in the process of transitioning
mitigation authority
to local governments and people are
heading back to their workplaces
the transition process for each of these
areas has been strategic
and nevada's housing situation is no
different
we must transition out of our eviction
moratorium
but do so in a way that protects tenants
and landlords to the greatest extent
possible
that is why today i am announcing that i
will be issuing
an emergency directive that extends the
current state eviction moratorium
for two more months at the end of may
the state moratorium will come to an end
it will not be extended again
today's extension comes with one
additional requirement
when landlords provide notices to
tenants during this time period
they must repeat they must also include
information on how they on available
rental assistance programs
and how tenants can access them help is
available for those in need
but only if they know about it i have
also asked stakeholders across the state
to increase efforts to inform the public
on available rental assistance to ensure
nevadans can save their homes
and landlords can get the money they are
owed
as many of you know yesterday the cdc
issued an extension on the federal
eviction moratorium
for 90 days the cdc order out of
necessity
is broad and applies nationwide in
reality however
every state's eviction laws are
different with different eviction
notices
and different core procedures that's why
our state eviction moratorium
is so important during this transition
period
it will continue to provide clear
direction to courts
eliminating much of the confusion and
burden on judicial resources
and it will help keep eligible tenants
housed
additionally this two-month extension of
the state eviction moratorium
will allow much needed time for
stakeholders
throughout the state to ensure processes
are developed and programs are set
set up to be implemented effectively
thanks to president biden
and a majority of members from our
federal delegation the state is
receiving millions
in rental assistance from the american
rescue plan
on top of funding already received but
this money must get out the door
faster we don't want to send federal
money set aside specifically for rental
assistance
back to washington dc this money belongs
in nevada
by extending this moratorium my
expectation
is that all stakeholders will work
together to ensure systems are created
to get these dollars out the door faster
to help both landlords and tenants does
not make sense to put thousands of
tenants at risk of eviction
when rental assistance dollars are
available especially
especially when we know that massive
evictions
will cause public health concerns and
irreparable harm to nevada families
still struggling from the pandemic
and the reality is landlords are
struggling too
they deserve to be paid for the last
year and the money is there to make them
whole
i've asked all partners throughout the
state to do everything we can to get it
to them
originally i did not plan on extending
this moratorium today
but i'm not going to put thousands of
nevadans at risk of losing their homes
while funding exists to help them and
the landlords
by the end of this two months i expect
that plans are developed
and implemented to get rental assistance
into the hands of landlords
that keep tenants in their homes
additionally
this extension will allow more time for
nevadans to get vaccinated
and for our economy to continue to
recover which will help our housing
crisis as well
now more than ever there is hope on the
horizon for the end of this pandemic
our cases hospitalizations and
positivity rates
are continuing to drop because nevadans
have come together under the collective
goal
to slow the spread of this deadly virus
we're administering vaccine as fast as
our federal allocation
allows us we're closer to the end than
to beginning
but there's still a lot of work ahead
and it's because of you we're doing so
well
again at the end of may the eviction
moratorium for the state of nevada will
end
while the cdc protections will stay in
place for another 30 days
during that 30-day period eviction case
filings may resume in the courts
but renters will still be protected from
actual eviction
through the end of the cdc moratorium in
a moment
you're going to hear from some of the
stakeholders we have been working with
including kevin schiller from clark
county we have worked collaboratively
with clark county where 72 percent of
all state evictions are handled
in one court for example clark county is
working on a process to pre-qualify
tenants and landlords
for rental assistance so by the time of
the mediation or court hearing
timely payments of rental assistance can
resolve the case
but more importantly if the if the
landlords are being paid now
during this pause evictions will be
avoided
i've also invited shannon chambers from
home means nevada
will share more information on plans for
the next two months
finally we will hear from assembly
speaker jason fryerson
and senator majority leader nicole
cannazzaro
about ongoing work in the nevada
legislature that will align with the
60-day timeline as well
i want to thank them in advance for
their work to figure out what can be
done
legislatively to help both tenants and
landlords
at this time i'd like to turn it over to
shannon chambers
who will speak briefly and will be
followed by kevin schiller
thank you good afternoon governor syslak
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak
and thank you everybody on this call
today my name is shannon chambers i'm
the president of home means nevada
i'm also the nevada labor commissioner
so i get a unique perspective on all of
these issues
and i want to again thank the governor
and his staff for dedicating the
resources
and developing solutions on these issues
in october of 2020 homing's nevada
became responsible for the rental
eviction mediation program
that was created through the last
special session of the nevada
legislature
we deployed that program very rapidly
and very quickly and established a
website
specifically for the program called the
renter connect
this is a website that has a vast amount
of resources
for tenants landlords attorneys for the
courts for the mediators
to provide information on rental
assistance
legal aid various different issues
cdc declarations the tenant declarations
required under the moratorium
as the rental eviction mediation program
became
deployed we worked with the courts
mainly with the las vegas justice court
but with all the courts in the state of
nevada
to implement that program effectively
and quickly
so between the period of october 2020
through december of 2020
we processed over 1300 cases through the
rental eviction mediation program
there were many success stories through
that program and many tenants that were
able to stay
in their residence what we also realized
in working with the various partners and
the stakeholders
was that given the time frame of the
eviction
notice from eviction notice to the
eviction hearing
we were dealing with a very very short
time frame
and the ability to get tenants
prioritized for rental assistance
or for landlords to get prioritized to
obtain
rental assistance was a challenge so
home means nevada worked with the courts
the nevada supreme court
with the counties with the governor's
office with the different homeowner
organizations with the rental
associations
to try and come up with a plan to make
this process
much quicker and much more efficient so
in the past two months home means nevada
has been working with the other partners
to develop a plan that we will implement
over the next 60 days
part of that plan will be to prioritize
the cases
that are sitting in the court system now
the majority of those cases are in
las vegas justice court and clark county
so we will be working with them
extensively to prioritize those cases
to send those cases that are appropriate
for mediation
through mediation for the cases that are
not appropriate for mediation
to work with the courts and clark county
to prioritize those cases
for rental assistance if they are
eligible
so we are all committed to making this
plan work over the next 60 days
it has been my opinion as the president
of home means nevada that we cannot lose
any more time
and so why a moratorium does buy some
more time we have to be effective and
efficient
in how we process that time and how we
work through these issues
so over the next 60 days home means
nevada will be working with the other
partners like i said the courts
the counties the local jurisdictions
with the apartment associations with the
landlords
to develop a plan that will prioritize
rental assistance applications as they
go through the courts
or go through mediation and for those
that are
somewhere in between we will implement a
voluntary mediation program
so that tenants and landlords can sit
down with a mediator
and potentially work through their
issues and come to an agreement
the important point about mediation is
that it is free
it is free to the tenant it is free for
the landlord
and it is a very effective process that
can produce
very effective results i can tell you
from personal experience having
administered
the rental eviction mediation program we
heard testimonials from both landlords
and tenants
that they were so grateful to have the
opportunity to sit down
with a third party to work for their
issues
and to be pointed in the right direction
of rental assistance and where they
needed to go
again that's only part of the solution
but it is a big part of the solution
that will become another building block
for the courts to work through
and for the counties to work through and
to make this process
again a much more efficient and
effective process
and to prioritize those cases that do
need to prioritize for rental assistance
and to get those decisions in a very
quick
and timely manner so that cases do not
end up in the courts
when this latest moratorium
ends at the end of may so again home
means nevada is
more than grateful to be part of this
and to be tasked with this
by the governor's office and by the
governor himself and we look forward
to working with all those partners going
forward and at this time i'd like to
introduce kevin schiller who is the
assistant county manager
for clark county who will play a very
very big part
in implementing this plan and mr
schiller has been very great to work
with
and appreciate his time and effort so go
ahead mr schiller thank you very much
thank you shannon um i first want to
thank governor sisselak and his staff
on behalf of clark clowney for their
continued efforts especially as we
battle this pandemic and face evictions
and both the tenants and the landlords
on that note with this 60-day
extension i think two pieces that i want
to make sure i highlight
is we had changes in the rental
assistance programming and eligibility
requirements that occurred
at the end of december going into
january with the consolidated
appropriations act
of 2021 some of those key tenants
is we obviously are extending 60 days
and we need people to get
applications into the queue um that
website
is chap.clarkcountynv.gov
again chap.clarkcounty.mv.gov
if you are in the queue or if you are
not in the queue either way you need to
go
in and update your application two new
two main requirements that have occurred
is obviously the tenant must apply it
can no longer be applied for by your
landlord if that occurred in your
previous process
um it needs to be applied for by you at
this point um
documentation is a critical component of
this for all of you out there that are
listening so you have to do two main
pieces one is proof of income
which will be tied to your tax returns
pay stubs
unemployment insurance payments so you
can prove that
other piece is landlord documentation
tied to your statement of arrears
and then also your landlord will be
putting in a w-9 at some of that
documentation
two key pieces that i want to make sure
i emphasize to this again
is if you are in the queue you have your
spot in line in the queue and we have
continued to process applications while
we update those requirements
if you're in that queue and you update
those within the next 30 days you
maintain your spot within that
if you are applying as a new applicant
you need to get on there as soon as
possible to get that documentation
and that completed application what does
the income eligibility mean so
if you are eighty percent of affordable
median income the translation for you
is i was giving the example a family of
four could earn up to about 60
000 there's more detail on the website
specifically tied to this
and we want to make sure in that
documentation that you can provide
that one one member of your household
was impacted by covit
another piece that i want to make sure
is very clear is we have updated our
portal
so that that documentation can be
uploaded quickly
and then on the landlord side there will
also be an updated portal in about 10
days where you can upload that
information from the landlord side
residency and citizenship you must be a
resident of clark county
undocumented individuals are eligible
for rental assistance
in follow-up to ms chambers i want to
emphasize we are working with the
eviction courts and we currently have
data from them specific to evictions
that have been filed
if you have received an eviction notice
at any level
it is very important that you respond to
that eviction
while we're working on your application
and your process so i want to put out
two numbers one is to legal aid of
southern nevada
702 386-1070
or
your um 702-671-3976 notice and or
process if you are in the eviction queue
we are prioritizing that through work
with our partners and miss chambers and
legal aid so what we will be doing is
reaching out to you
and you may be hearing from us sooner
rather than later as we have a list of
those currently
to give some sense on time frames one of
the key pieces is when we
ended the initial rental assistance
based on the initial federal allocation
there were still 12 000 applications
that were sitting in that queue
when we started with our next round of
federal funding that is what's currently
being utilized that will serve up to
approximately 40 000 households
um in total at a total of 161 million
dollars in conjunction with the state
and local jurisdictions dollars
again i want to emphasize if you are in
the queue you must go in go back to the
website and update
your information and if you are
listening to this and are in crisis
we need to make sure you go to
chap.clarkcountynb.gov
and get your information in um with that
i really want to extend a
gracious thanks to governor sissellac
and all the stakeholders
in relationship to this as we really
want to get these dollars out over the
next
60 days and prioritize those
needs the last piece is if you contact
the other pieces that i want to make
sure everybody is aware
we will be working on rehousing if you
apply for assistance and you aren't
eligible we still have you in our queue
to work on re-housing you and getting
you
into an apartment or into a residence so
that you are not homeless
and with that i'll hand it back to
governors
thank you shannon and kevin both for
being here and joining us today and
providing this important update
as i mentioned i have also invited
speaker fryerson
and majority leader ken azaru to be here
and speak briefly today
so with that i'll introduce speaker
jason fryerson
thank you governor and and thank you all
for being here today
um as you all know we're coming out of a
crisis brought on by covet
19 and the pandemic uh nevadas are going
back to work
kids are going back to school uh but but
the impacts uh from the pandemic
uh they'll linger beyond the transition
to this new
new normal nevada families are looking
for us to help them get back on their
feet
uh and extending the eviction more
toward will allow us to do that
uh this extension gives state local and
county entities time to fine-tune and
implement
procedures to give rental assistance uh
dollars to landlords as well as tenants
more quickly and efficiently uh it also
gives the legislature and other elected
bodies
time to work with stakeholders to make
sure that our landlords
and our tenants have access uh to
available assistance dollars
uh as we receive more federal rental
assistance dollars to help landlords
and tenants pay their rent back uh we
can also make sure that we have programs
in place
to ensure that we utilize as much of
this assistance as possible
um you know we have of course gotten
direction from the federal government on
uh the federal uh moratorium and so it
makes sense that we would follow suit
and try to partner up with our
stakeholders
in order to uh best you know meet the
needs of both
uh tenants as well as landlords and and
as the governor pointed out
um this is about both tenants and
landlords this is about
our community so i'm looking forward to
working with the governor
the senate and stakeholders over the
next two months to ensure that
our tenants and also our landlords are
protected as we transition to a new
phase
of this pandemic so uh with that i
wanted to turn it over to my colleague
in the senate uh majority leader nicole
cannizzaro
who we have been also working with with
the governor and other stakeholders to
to try to
come up with ways to come out of this
situation keeping everybody in their
homes
i'm sorry majority leader you're on mute
still
thank you thank you speaker fryerson um
for your introduction i wanted to take
the time to thank governor sislak for
taking action today
to extend our state's eviction
moratorium we're all very excited of
course to see that vaccinations
are increasing daily that cases are
dropping and that signs are there are
signs that our economy is beginning to
recover
but we know that many families are still
suffering from the public health and
economic consequences
of the coven 19 pandemic and for many
families
one of those consequences is the risk of
losing their homes
i think we all agree that an eviction
crisis would be devastating for
nevadans and our economic recovery as
well as our
our landlords who have been weathering
the storm and is absolutely critical
that we prevent thousands of nevada
families
from being thrown into any more turmoil
because of a situation that is
beyond their control what's important to
note
as we have this conversation is that we
have resources available through federal
aid programs
to provide direct rental assistance to
nevadans who are struggling with their
rent
and also to provide assistance to those
landlords who have been
also working through this pandemic in
fact nearly 90 million in rental
assistance has already been distributed
through state and local partnerships
but with tens of millions and relief
still it relief aids still available and
potentially more coming
what we need is more time to get that
money out the door
today is extension the addition of new
notice requirements
for landlords and other steps to
streamline the rental assistance program
outlined by our partners will help
ensure that that happens
over the remaining two months i very
much look forward
to during this legislative session
working with local jurisdictions
our state agencies and our community
partners to assist renters to get caught
up on their rent
and to provide that critical assistance
to our landlords we're ready and willing
to work on legislative initiatives that
can help our local partners speed up
distribution
help keep tenants in their homes and
stop preventable income losses
for property owners if nevadans who are
renters take away any message from today
it is that there is
help available if you are facing a
potential eviction or housing crisis
and it's not too late i look forward to
working with speaker fryerson and my
legislative colleagues
to ensure that we can tackle this issue
comprehensively over the next two months
i also wanted to thank the governor for
his leadership throughout this pandemic
and for those of you who are paying
attention and are our renters and our
landlords
please know that there is help available
and that if you need help to make sure
that you please do apply today
and thank you again for um for having me
today
thanks thank you both very much for
being here i could not ask for two
better partners to work through this
entire pandemic crisis with and
to you and your colleagues i can't thank
you enough for everything that you do on
a daily basis
uh and thank you for your commitment to
working together for the next two months
on this extremely critical issue
before we take questions i want to speak
directly to nevadans
if you are nervous about losing your
home because you've been negatively
impacted
by this pandemic now right now is the
time to engage
with rental assistance programs please
take advantage of this
help is here but it's up to you
i want to reiterate nevada's eviction
moratorium will end in
two months and the cdc moratorium ends
in
three months or 90 days it's my
expectation that stakeholders will work
together
to get all of these pieces into place to
protect tenants
and landlords thank you very much
i encourage you to continue to wear
masked socially distance
and bring an endless pandemic and i'll
now take some questions
and megan is going to take the lead here
thank you governor thank you majority
leader speaker
shannon and kevin for joining the
governor today i see
i already have some hands up on the zoom
if you'd like to get in the line to ask
a question
please use the raise hand feature you
can find that under reactions
we'll go to terry russell for the first
question and tiffany
you're on deck thank you governor i'd
like to know if you know at this point
how much money is being sent to the
state under this program
uh the rules of it i.e
when does it have to be spent the money
and what percentage of the money goes to
renters and what percentage goes to the
landlords thank you
thanks for that question terry i
actually think that shannon
chambers from home means nevada might
have some of those figures
um readily available
so actually megan it's probably kevin
schiller that would be
better expert on that because they're
actually distributing the funds
uh for the record uh kevin schiller so
um on the funding component side of this
speaking specifically to the allocation
in clark county there will be a total of
161 million dollars what's a combination
of city of las vegas city of henderson
north las vegas clark county's funding
and the state's uh approximate 92
million
to support the programming to your
second question
on um how much goes to tenants and how
much goes to landlords so the
way the process works is a statement of
arrears is
given to us in that application process
under that treasury guidance once they
are deemed eligible
we provide payment for that total
arrears to the landlord directly
there is the ability to play the client
directly after you've exhausted efforts
and other means
but the primary issue is getting the
dollars to the tenant
or to the landlord based on the tenant's
arrears
um in the current process here we will
be paying at the point that that is
approved we will pay within the month
that they actually were approved going
back all the way in their
ears
thank you terry we'll go to tiffany for
the next question and then colton
hello um governor thank you so much for
taking my question i know that
this is a plan in place with the
eviction moratorium being extended
for the next two months but what is the
long-term plan
um i'm assuming that you know even after
two months that not all of the
assistance will get to everyone who
needs it
what's the plan in the long run so that
people don't end up in the streets
uh over the next few years following
just the impacts from coven 19.
well clearly we want to do everything we
can to keep people in their homes to
keep them
safe and to keep them housed
what we need to do is get we've extended
the moratorium twice since i initially
put it in place
already this is the last extension for
the moratorium
the eviction process will have to start
taking place in fact after
60 days people will be able to go into
court landlords will
and file but nobody will be evicted for
the remaining 30 days of the cdc
uh we are hopeful and i'm confident that
we will get back to our new normal
this is their situation when with a lot
of different issues whether it's
giving the control back to the local
counties for jurisdiction
whether this is getting people back to
closer occupancy in some of our
businesses
more capacity and so forth we're getting
back to the new normal and uh
this is another one of the items that is
going to be coming back to the new
normal
as we get through this uh extension
thanks for the question tiffany and i'm
sorry i didn't get my words out fast
enough when terry asked her question
we'll be happy to send you more
specifics on the dollars coming to
nevada from federal sources specifically
for rental assistance i'll follow up
with you on that
so we'll go look colton for the next
question and then austin you're on deck
shannon mentioned that they that the
programs would be prioritizing
people or cases that are currently in
the court system
and i'm guessing that's the eviction's
currently in the system
is there an estimate or a number as to
how many people in nevada are currently
facing evictions
so thank you for the question colton so
this is shannon again so
the estimates in clark county is over 3
500
that are kind of in the court system
right now so that's the best information
in the court system now i have seen data
that again with clark county being the
largest
population and biggest county that it's
anywhere between five to seven percent
of residents potentially facing eviction
in clark county alone
but the main goal right now in
implementing this plan over the next 60
days is
to address those court cases that are
sitting there right now
so that those individuals if they're
eligible for rental assistance can get
that assistance
so that they don't go back into a cycle
of facing eviction
that they may have been facing two
months ago when the previous moratorium
was extended
thank you shannon thanks for the
question colton we'll go to austin and
then michelle rendells will be next
hey megan and governor syslag thank you
so much for taking my question now just
last week we had reported that 23
000 households in clark county uh still
have not received that rental assistance
i know you guys now are urging people to
fill out those applications if they need
the help
but what do you say to some of the
tenants and landlords that we've spoken
to just over the past couple weeks and
months who
you know did the right thing their
applications were in and they are still
waiting on that funding
what can they do right now what what
piece of advice can you give them
thanks for the question austin kevin did
you want to speak to
uh that process i think you did a little
bit in your remarks
absolutely um austin so two key pieces
and i touched on this a little bit
um at the point that uh funding in the
initial
federal rental assistance came forward
in december
when that funding was exhausted there
were about 12 000 individuals that were
sitting in that queue
since january we received an additional
over a thousand a week
in those applications specific to your
question of what to tell people and
people that are sitting you are in the
queue
and we are processing based on the new
requirements
two key pieces though that i would focus
on is um we had to update our portal
with all the new federal requirements
based on the second round of dollars so
that went into
effect about two weeks ago um with that
prior to that we had uh processed and
upwards of about four to forty five
hundred applications in a manual process
so people that are sitting there
their application is in the queue the
key piece i want to get out and if you
get asked questions about this is make
sure they go in and update their
application
based on the new requirements and the
documentation that is the critical piece
so that it can be expedited once we get
to it
again the total numbers i want to make
sure i talk to that
when you talk about 23 000 the issue of
total households will be able to serve
is about 40
000 um so there's plenty of room in that
queue for people to apply and get their
documentation in and then we anticipate
on a weekly basis processing it's an
upwards
of about 2 300 applications a week
towards approval so that's the number
where we're shooting with in terms of
those weekly averages
thank you austin and thank you kevin
we'll do i think i said michelle
rendells and then we'll do jaclyn and
then i think that's all the questions we
have so after those two we'll pull to a
close
hi governor thanks for taking the
question um
i wanted to ask if you have any plans to
lift the state's mask mandate as we've
seen in other states
and if not um what metrics are you
going to use to decide when to do that
i have made a commitment uh michelle
that i you know nevada
las vegas in particular when you're
talking about the strip is going to be
the safest healthiest place to come
visit
and i'm going to continue to follow
through with that commitment
we have no intention of lifting the mask
mandate and my
commitment right now and my efforts are
being put into vaccinations i want to
get a needle into every arm that we
possibly can
and if the time comes or when the time
comes that we can lift the mask mandate
we'll go ahead but an immediate
foreseeable future we are not lifting
the mass mandate
i want to make it like say a safe place
for people to come on vacation
safe place for conventions and meetings
and mask wearing
and social distancing protocols and the
like are part of that
equation thank you governor thanks
michelle we'll go to jacqueline and then
i see a couple more hands popped up so
we'll see if we have time to
get a couple more in good afternoon
everyone
for kevin or for shannon in particular
i've heard from a lot of either tenants
or landlords
the chaps application can be clunky and
a big barrier
to completing it is participation
sometimes the landlord does not want to
participate
and then the tenant has trouble being
able to get
the application in or the landlord has a
tenant that's not cooperative
how do these new processes in place
where the tenant has to apply
how can that maybe help the parties here
so this is kevin i'll go first um two
pieces one
is your comments are not far off
there has been a lot of frustration
around both ends in terms of
participation
uh two things i would emphasize one on
the applicant side we are actually
launching with multiple non-profits
essentially a support
system that will be reaching out to all
those clients in terms of hand-holding
and helping them get documentation in so
that's a critical piece
um on the landlord side i mentioned it
in my comments that we are going live
with a
secondary access point for landlords
only to the portal
that purpose is because when they
download w9 tax information and
information that they may not want to
share
it will maintain confidentiality and it
doesn't go to the clients it actually
goes directly into the portal so those
are two key pieces that we're working
towards and then
i'll kick the shannon but i know also on
the mediation side they've experienced
same uh frustrations that we've tried to
work through in terms of our support
protocols
no and i would just echo what mr
schiller said that through the mediation
part of it
that we are going to devote staff to
help the tenants
tenants and help the landlords get the
documents that are required
help them with the application process
and and the term
is hand-holding and what we found is
that
many individuals need help they need
help navigating
the portal they need help knowing
exactly what documents they need and
through the mediation process that's
where a mediator can help
but working in conjunction with kevin's
staff we feel confident that
taking that extra step to really give
them some personal
attention in that application process
will make a big difference
thank you for the question and with the
governor's go ahead i think we'll
maybe take a couple more um
we'll get some of the folks who haven't
had a chance to ask a question yet we'll
start with orco
and then we'll go to sam
everyone thank you so much for taking my
question i know you said we have
um several hundred people in the court
system right now waiting and i would
imagine
more people will join uh now with this
update
with the eviction moratorium here ending
at the end of
may is there a kind of a a cut-off point
where
if they start the process regardless of
it
regardless of if it's you know we are
past
may will they be able to go through the
process without getting evicted
or is the end of may a hard deadline
so this is shannon i can't speak to what
the legislature
might do through the end of this session
what i can tell you is the existing laws
that govern eviction
are very fast so it's typically a 30 to
45 day process
what's also important to remember under
the cdc moratorium and
under the governor's numeratorium is
there are certain evictions that can
still go forward because they don't
involve
anything related to covid so you know at
the end of may
obviously home means nevada will work
with the courts and work with the
supreme court and work with the partners
to evaluate what court cases we've been
able to get through
um in the previous 60 days and then
going forward there will likely be some
cases that will end up in the court
system
but the option there would then be is
they have the option of requesting
mediation
so there might be some cases that do end
up in eviction but there might be some
cases after the moratorium ends that go
through
mediation and there's a resolution
that's able to be worked out
thank you i think kevin wanted to add
something here and then we'll go to
sam's question
yeah i just wanted to add to your
question i think a good question and one
of the key pieces
is because of this process that's been
initiated by the state in conjunction
with all the stakeholders in the courts
we actually have the list of those set
evictions that we're working through but
to your point of those that are in a
process and what that outcome may look
like we also are automatically putting
them into
if they are at the risk of homelessness
and let's say the eviction goes through
we have them in a rapid rehousing
program
and that happens at a statewide level
also so we will have them in the queue
to re-house them to avoid the
homelessness so there's a
somewhat of a safety net and a service
array that's sitting there which is
actually very opportunistic and and
hasn't occurred with the courts
historically so this has been a
a great collaboration thank you and i
think we'll take
a final question from sam and we can
follow up with additional questions
um afterward we want to make sure we let
folks like shannon and kevin get back to
processing applications
um as quickly as possible so sam i think
we'll go ahead with you for the last
question
hi thank you for taking my question
apologies if i haven't done my homework
on the differences between the state and
federal moratorium
um you said that the importance of
having a state moratorium on top of the
cdc's
stem from every state having different
eviction laws
i'm wondering by that logic why we don't
align our timeline with the federal
government's moratorium
which ends in 90 days rather than 60.
you want me to go on that one megan sure
governor
okay the idea was that the cdc came in
at 90 days
ours is a little different than the
federals uh
the cdc moratorium is we want an
opportunity for after the 60 days
expires
that someone a landlord can go in and
start to file papers
no one can get evicted while the cdc
moratorium is in place
they'll still be protected they won't
become homeless and won't lose their
housing
but it'll get our process started while
the
clock runs on the cdc moratorium
thank you and i think unless shannon or
kevin have anything to add we'll pull to
a close today thank you all
for joining us and for being here um if
you have
any additional questions feel free to
reach out to me and we'll get you
answers as quickly as we can so with
that governor if you have anything to
add before we close
yeah i appreciate megan i want to give
jason and nicole a chance and say just a
closing remark if they have one
i want to thank everyone for
participating today we're doing
everything we can
to get the landlords and the tenants and
the money all connected so we can get
the money into the hands
of the landlords and i want to have
another shout out to treasurer zach
conan who's been an incredible partner
in terms of working through these
processes and chief justice hardesty to
get the money into people's hands
and please continue to do everything you
can to assist us
in stopping the spread of covet continue
to wear a mask to practice social
distancing
and when you're eligible for a vaccine
which everyone is going to be
everyone over the age of 16 is going to
be eligible this monday
as soon as you're eligible please make
an appointment
go get the vaccine and we're closer to
the end than where the beginning but
ever getting everyone vaccinated is an
important part of that so
uh jason or nicole are you there do you
have a ques anything you want to add in
uh sure governor i i again thank you for
for your commitment in this regard
i'll just say this i i want all of the
stakeholders to know that we
have heard you we understand that there
are tenants in need
but we also understand that there are
landlords in need
uh we understand that this has to be a
balanced approach
and i uh am excited to hear the progress
that's been made in particular in clark
county
about being able to expedite the
processing which has been uh held up for
some time
largely due to federal requirements for
qualifications and eligibility so
um it sounds like we have worked through
a lot of that and we are ready
to get going and get relief where it's
needed um we hear your realtors we hear
you landlords and we hear you uh tenants
and we are we are committed to making
sure that we expedite resolving this to
to keep everybody in their homes and
make sure that we make uh folks that are
hurting as whole as we possibly can
and and thank you again governor i it's
this really does take i think a team
effort and all of us working together to
ensure
that we can get relief um to tenants and
also to the to the speaker's point to
landlords who have been
sort of weathering the storm along with
us and i think this is a good step in
the right direction to ensure that we
can get funds
um where they need to go and to keep
people in their homes
and start to get you know this state
back on a path to recovery which i think
we have seen and have to continue to
build on and we're going to be able to
do that together
i'm working through the next 60 days
with the legislature
and with the governor's office and just
really appreciate the opportunity
to be able to work out this plan so that
we can have that balanced approach that
the speaker mentioned
in tackling this issue and thank you
again for having us here and
looking forward to working with you over
the next 60 days
thank you both for joining us i
sincerely appreciate it once again
please
when you get a chance to get your
vaccine take a shot for nevada
thank you